I got a voicemail uh from an astrologist
now I don't believe in any of this stuff
but here is an astrologist explaining
how Donald Trump still has 35 approval
take a listen to this
hello David I'm astrologer I've been on
a TV show similar to astrologer not an
astrologist sorry a Dragonstone
Trump's astrology chart uh years ago I'm
pretty accurate anyways in your video
Trump approval plunges to lowest in a
year you were scared that felt 30 some
percent
approve of him yeah guess what there's
uh in astrology there's 30 degrees in
each sign and 10 degrees of them are
always in what's called cusp half of
half on sign half of another
and
thirty percent of the calendar is in
cost thirty percent of Trump supporters
are
Trump has free transport they're all
cusps I guarantee you they're all born
around the 221st two three days in
between the 21st of the month
that's how you that's how 33 of the
people still believe in Trump
uh because astrology
serious geology charts they're fooled by
it they're they're half of one side half
of another and they're confused they're
built-in conflict that's how it works
yeah I don't believe in any of that
astrology is just not scientific even
put aside the concept of people's
personalities and lives being influenced
by the position of planets when they
were born
most of the astrology charts aren't even
actually accurate for the time that we
were born so like at its face it doesn't
make any sense but I always love hearing
an interesting voicemail and so I
appreciate it nonetheless even though I
don't believe in any of it we have a
great bonus show for you today we are
going to talk about hurricane Ian we're
going to talk about Edward Snowden
getting Russian citizenship from
Vladimir Putin and we will talk about
the latest in the Matt Gates
investigation charges likely not
forthcoming not forthcoming oh the bonus
show where
all of those stories on two days bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com to get
instant access